muslim
well the qurani app is about to show you
your progress with your soul not only
does it encourage you to read it tells
you how many verses you've read how many
pages you read how long you've been on
it and best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
salaam alaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah may i also
tell you bless every single one of you
guys today i'm going to be reacting to a
video which
when i saw this video it actually really
touched my heart
because i saw the innocence and i saw
the sincerity
uh in this man's heart and this is
arsenal tv
um and basically let's watch it together
i'm not going to keep you guys long
but even watching this one since i'm
feeling a little bit like emotional in
the context where
it reminds me of a companion of an uh
called a man
and he was someone who was known to have
an addiction
towards alcohol that was his
shortcomings but we're going to learn
lessons from both of them let's get
straight into the video inshallah and
see this because i think it's going to
really
melt your heart inshallah so here we go
here's the video in charlotte of this um
brother in arsenal tv let's go
[Laughter]
christopher
i'm getting shivers you know you know
why i'm getting chills bombs says i
don't know if you feel the same way as i
do
but for him to look on the floor and be
like the guys i don't see you fasting
and he's like yeah like i'm a bad muslim
but i'm a muslim
that touched me wallahi that really
touched me because you can see the
sincerity
in his eyes and the love he has for
allah and his messenger
but let's carry on let's carry on
because this is a very important
reminder
to the mosque long time years ago oh wow
i don't drink though i do not drink you
don't drink here
it was a long time ago it's terrible i
don't i don't eat pork
obviously other meats aren't available
well you wouldn't be if you're a
vegetarian or whatever you are no
i'm not gonna eat that
now this is just one part so he's making
it very clear to them that he's a muslim
yeah
and you can see subhanallah says it's
you know the approach that we should
have towards other believers should be
nothing but love you know but to see him
where he's putting his head down and be
like yeah i'm a bad muslim but i am a
muslim
to me that touches my heart while he to
me
anyways but what's really disturbing
here is what happens next
let's see come on come on down here
come on no thank you
that would be nice
come on guys all right do at least half
no thank you
why not because i don't drink alcohol
come on no thank you i don't know
come on no no i don't drink your uncle
john robbie what are you saying
now that that is disgusting you know you
know very clearly he's a muslim to go
there
and down it down it like a little pirate
clown uh down it down and you can see
that they are actually mocking the sky
yeah they're literally not taking this
guy seriously they're taking for a mug
yeah that's what they're doing and even
though they're taking from monkeys
somebody who obeys allah's messenger he
could have easily fall
and feel in inferiority complex and let
me fit in he's like
no and this is someone bob and sisters
who you know he reminds me of
it reminds me of a companion called no
no iman
you know he was somebody who was known
for his humor
known for the jokes i would make and he
also had an addiction with
alcohol but brothers and sisters
once he went to the marketplace and
bought some food and
he liked the taste of it so much he
ordered it for the mystery of allah he
ordered
the the the person uh who owned the shop
two take some to the messenger of allah
when the person took it to the messenger
of allah the process said 80
the man said can you pay me and he said
pay you he said they said well yeah
because nuai man
told me to send this to you and when
they called nu iman and they said
look what's going on you sent this to us
the mystery of allah and the prophet
saws
and he said no iman you send this as
like a gift but they're asking me for
the money
he said the message of allah you know
you have to pay you know i liked it and
i wanted you to have it as well but
doesn't mean i've got to pay
yeah the thing was the sincerity in the
context where he wanted it for the
process
even though he didn't have the money to
pay for it and the process laughed about
it so much but you know what's really
profound about this companion
is that he was he fought in the battle
of badr
and oh if i'm not mistaken he fought but
he had a
a a weakness with alcohol one day
he was i think he was flogged once or
two times okay we know the
punishment for um drinking alcohol if
i'm not mistaken
did 80 lashes because he believed that
the one who drinks alcohol is more prone
to slander and this the lashes for
standard is
80 100 something sorry it might be 100
yeah um
i think it's 80 for zina is 100 sorry so
yeah
so now look at this on the third time oh
my god
we're so angered that these guys keep
doing this and the mystery of allah
imagine the messenger of allah
and he's doing and he said may allah
curse you
he said may allah curse you the prophet
salallahu just imagine today if that
happened
these super these these super these
individuals yeah some arrogant people
who are
in today's time while this guy is
misguided
this guy is an evildoer this guy's this
and that
look at the messenger of allah you know
what he did did he stop it
did he say no don't say don't say uh
may allah curse you did he say that
i mean did he say no carry on saying may
allah curse him no he said don't say
that to him
because he loves allah and his messenger
this brother on arsenal tv if you guys
know it send this video to him
because i can see from his eyes the love
he has for allah and his messenger
yeah i can see the aki may allah bless
you and keep you from and get you closer
but anytime you have doubts remember no
iman
he had an addiction as well yeah and
subhanallah i know that i'm saying here
additionally you don't drink it but what
i'm trying to say is
that you love allah i know you're saying
i'm a bad muslim we are all bad
we are trying our best to get close all
of us so subhan allah says this is what
it teaches you
it teaches you to have mercy towards the
believers and i wanted to do this video
because it really touched
my heart and i'm going to end on this
note brothers and sisters the prophet
peace be upon him said
a companion a good friend yeah is
like for example brown sisters if you go
to a blacksmith yeah a bad friend is
like
somebody who's a blacksmith when you go
there even if you don't do nothing even
if he doesn't give you any harm it tells
you to do evil stuff
you standing there you are going to be
left with marks and
smell the least and the good friend is
that
the one who sells musk even if he was
not to tell you to do anything good
the fact that you remain around him you
will end up smelling good
the benefits that it brings so my dear
brother changed
this arsenal team whatever it may be
your friends or companions because
you can clearly see they have no respect
to you and that's about your brothers
and sisters hope you guys benefited
and one message one last message to my
brother here allah subhanahu ta'ala says
in the quran
i would have been lying in the
a
[Music]
all my servants are transgressed against
themselves do not
ever despair the mercy of the lord
because your lord
is most forgiving most merciful
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh